a bag of natural deodorant does not work
folks just so you all know aremy oat is
that spicy supremely spicy hummus just
got me going alright hey guys I'm Abbey
shark welcome to Abbey's kitchen tis the
season for holiday entertaining and I've
parted up with my friends at Sabra
hummus who sponsored this video helped
me create an impressive and tasty spread
without spending all week in the kitchen
so as you guys probably know this is the
first year that I have another human
growing inside of me so I don't have the
same stamina for a cooking marathon this
year so I've been relying on Sabra
hummus for a simple and flavorful
appetizer I like Sarah hummus because
it's got a really authentic flavor a
super creamy consistency and it comes
with a variety of yummy yummy toppings
so it feels like a fancy appetizer but I
honestly just have to pull it out the
fridge and serve now on a normal
Saturday night I could totally plow
through an entire container with a bag
of baby carrots or pita chips but
forgets I like to go all out so I've got
three unique dippers that you're gonna
love let's do this first up my crispy
baked sweet potato chips
I start by preheating an oven to 425
degrees and then adding some sliced
sweet potatoes to a bowl with some olive
oil smoked sweet paprika and some salt
give everything a good mix to make sure
that all the spices are evenly coating
the potatoes then transfer them to a
baking sheet lined with parchment paper
making sure that none of the sweet
potatoes are touching transfer it to an
oven for about 12 minutes until they're
crispy and golden brown and get dipping
these sweet potato chips go so well with
sabra's pie net hummus next up my
parmesan pizza twists pre-heat your oven
to 425 degrees and then in a bowl mix
together some Parmesan cheese red pepper
flakes garlic powder and salt give it a
good stir to get all those flavors
combined put a little bit of flour down
onto a wooden surface and then roll out
your pizza dough into a nice thin log
[Music]
cover the dough generously with our
parmesan mixture and then top that off
with some big dots of pesto you can use
store-bought or homemade whatever you've
got on hand will work give it a good
spread to make sure that all those
flavors are evenly distributed and then
slice the pizza dough into nice thin
strips
[Music]
place the strip's onto a baking sheet
lined with parchment paper and then
gently twist them to reveal some nice
little bits of pesto peeking through
brush them with a little bit of olive
oil
[Music]
and then top them off with the remaining
parmesan mixture pop these into the oven
for about 12 minutes till golden and
crispy and then get dipping my favorite
combination are these pizza twists with
sappers roasted garlic hummus
[Music]
finally at my baked zucchini fries
[Music]
again pre-heat your oven to 425 degrees
and then in one bowl add some beaten
eggs with another bowl for your Parmesan
cheese bread crumbs paprika cumin and
salt
give it a good mix to get all those
flavors incorporated then dip your
zucchini into the eggs and then into the
breadcrumb mixture transfer your little
zucchini fries onto a baking sheet lined
with parchment paper and then bake them
off about 20 minutes until they're
golden brown crispy my favourite dipping
combination is combine these with baked
zucchini fries with cyber's to creme Li
spicy comments guys if I can pull off
planning prepping and hosting the
holidays
you totally can too well I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with how you would incorporate
Fabri into your holiday spread check out
the link below for an exclusive coupon
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
you
you